hello I'm Dustin Kirkland a product
manager at Google I'm here with Tim
Hawken tech lead for the kubernetes
project at Google Tim you've been around
kubernetes since the beginning you've
seen the past the present and maybe have
some ideas about the future walk us
through the past present and future of
kubernetes sure so you know kubernetes
was born at Google obviously took a lot
of ideas from Google but it is not
exclusively a Google thing it is is this
community is amazing thing that has
happened the past you know we've spent
five years building this system we're
here now with 8,000 of my best friends
talking about committees it's amazing to
have gotten here five years ago I would
never have believed that we would be
here in Spain talking about this here we
are today we're still working in
communities it is still maturing it is
servicing a way more than we initially
thought we would possibly be able to
address more use cases more users more
scale and in future you know it's still
growing we're still doing more we're
tackling new use cases every day we got
customers and users here all the time
talking about this new use case this new
problem and so I'm excited to see how
much more we're gonna grow tackle and
what's new and Google is one of the
leaders in the kubernetes project but
not the only one there's a lot of
vendors involved in in and around
kubernetes and and other projects how do
you see the role of vendors in in and
around the kubernetes community I'm one
of the tech leads of the project I work
on a lot of different areas within the
project obviously and I oversee a lot of
work and I work at Google and you might
think that would be conflicting but I
think it's it's not really the leads of
the project are very much fanatic
fanatical about being vendor-neutral
about being open about being very
transparent the project is set up in a
way that everything we do can be seen by
anybody who wants to pay attention and I
think that show is in the quality of the
code the quality and number of
contributors where they're coming from
we have contributors from every time
zone on the planet from almost every
continent I still haven't proved whether
we have someone in Antarctica or not
during Antarctica and you're
contributing to communities call me this
has been a really important part the
vendors are critical piece of our
ecosystem kubernetes would not be
successful without the ecosystem we knew
this from the beginning and I would
happy to say that we're really
successful there but it is still a
community driven project that is not
tied or locked into any one vendor while
we have a ton of people at Google who
are working on kubernetes myself
included they are not exclusively
focusing on Google's work they're
working to build the project a bit large
and you have you've got a lot of insight
with with a lot of customers a lot of
users and a lot of community members
working with kubernetes what are some of
the trends you see emerging maybe some
unexpected trends that you are patterns
you've seen emerge so I do I talk to a
lot of customers and I've definitely
seen some emerging trends we've passed
the point where people are struggling to
figure out if they need kubernetes it's
more or less assumed now if you're
building big systems kubernetes is the
way to do it but the patterns that were
merging now are scale large size how big
can my clusters get how many pods can I
run on a node what what's the density
that I can achieve
how do I Drive my utilization we're
talking about multi cluster situations
I've got clusters around the world
around the country how do I link them
together and make them work together
some of these problems are sort of at
the very edges of kubernetes itself but
I think there's a lot we can do within
kubernetes to make it easier to build
solutions that are solving these
problems hybrid is a really hot topic
right now the reality of you know people
are stuck in other clouds or they're
stuck on premises and there are really
good reasons for that and they're trying
to find ways to work across these
different environments Tim thank you
very much
[Music]
you